Hey look guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at github and
hazel and how all that kind of work
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already because today we're
actually gonna be continuing on with the
whole github thing and taking a look at
pull requests and apart from just taking
a look at them and integrating some of
them today we're also going to discuss
how in the future you should collaborate
vehicle requests so I think this is like
a really useful topic for everyone it's
also gonna be very useful outside of
hazel because if you're working with
github if you're working with kind of
teams of people that you're using get an
advisor it doesn't really matter what
version control system you're really
using pull requests and just that whole
notion of being able to kind of you know
create code as a team and then merge it
together and all that and you know break
off into your own feature branches or
bug fix branches or anything like
anything like that really vital for
software engineering in general I tend
to make a lot of videos on the
technicalities of actually writing code
but then I realize that a lot of people
ask me well how does this work if I'm in
a team right if I'm in a team of people
and we're all working on the same thing
how does this work because all of my
videos I'm kind of the only one really
working on them and so because of that I
don't and because I'm teaching you guys
like a specific thing I'm not spending
too much time being like well if this
was more in a team environment and which
did this or that so I'm gonna spend a
little bit of time kind of talking about
that today as well but hopefully we can
just kind of sort through these pull
requests we have 7 open full requests
other right now
don't forget the repository for hazel is
in the description of every video
definitely check that out if you have
code that you want to change or if you
notice that I make a mistake and you
want to fix it or you want to go ahead
and just add something that you think is
useful then definitely open a pull
request or an issue because at the very
least we'll discuss this and the
community we'll discuss this with you
and then that way you can kind of get to
grips with them with just you know the
whole software engineering workflow and
how we can pull this project together so
I'm really excited for all that let's
take a look at pull requests so we have
seven pull requests this is the hazel
repository of course is what it looks
like
read me wise I'm going to add a readme
very very soon and this will have
information on how to open pull requests
because there's there's a really things
that you want to have why do we have two
branches what's this it's the first time
I'm noticing this to be honest I have no
idea what that is
9th of December anyway whatever and so
we have we have this raid me file here
which will contain information on things
like how to build hazel and how to
submit pull requests and how to submit
issues and just information about
general collaboration so that is usually
a place and github where you would put
such information I haven't done that yet
but I will
but for now you can see that we have es6
issues and a bunch of pull requests and
some of these you can say it is coming
in pretty frequently and usually I will
kind of read these offline because
obviously you know every week we get
more and more of these and I can't make
an episode every week at least not at
this point where I can just go through
everything if that's something that you
guys want to see at some point I I'm
telling you right now it's not gonna
happen every week but maybe every month
or every two weeks or something like
that if you guys just want me to make a
video where I'm like okay let's just
filter through all these issues and pull
requests then I can probably do that but
but but in general I just you know what
I'm just on the train or something and I
have a spare moment I'll look at this on
my phone and just reply and just you
know kind of kind of keep that
discussion going so that's how I kind of
handle this stuff right now because
obviously I don't really have the time
to sit down at a computer and do all
this stuff because my life is just
hectic anyway so pull requests this is
what we're looking at today
so let's start from the beginning we've
actually got six of them closed already
I believe I like even for this one use
unique pointers instead of raw pointers
yeah like you can see that I responded
to this two thumbs down anyway
I responded to this quite a while ago
actually and I even gave some examples
and I you know gave some reasoning as to
why I decided to do what I did a certain
way so you know you know this is like a
pull request that actually
doesn't even seem to do any okay so it
does I don't know why the file changes
there but maybe that barrage has been
closed already it doesn't matter the
point is this is kind of the spirit of
pull request right like you know you
know done this and that obviously could
have opened an issue instead and asked
if this was reasonable to do or if
that's the direction we're going in but
this is also fine I don't mind doing
something like this and then you can see
that people just jump in and we have a
discussion going and then if I you know
don't like something or if I want to
discuss it further then I will kind of
you know do this and I mean I even like
linked to the CBP reference and stuff in
certain cases so it's kind of a good
exam
kind of like s lesson for everyone not
actually like lesson like I'm not trying
to be like my way is the correct way
it's more or less than in terms of like
some aspects of this that people might
not have thought about it's educational
for everyone to kind of just jump into
this discussion and participate so I
like it when people do that a lot
because these six different people but I
said in this one specifically and then I
didn't even close you know in the pull
request so it's not like I'm just like
BAM done that's it closed no the
original poster close the pull request
once I guess they were satisfied that
that's fine
so again this is really good for those
of you who doesn't you actually want to
learn how to be on a team and ride a
mansion and all of that instead of just
watching the videos and copying down the
code and trying to do everything
yourself jump into this seriously it's
really cool it's solid it's gonna give
you much more of a team kind of
experience and yeah I mean I'm I'm here
to just help you guys out and and again
there's gonna be so many cases of you
guys being like hey Cho know you're
completely wrong in this this is the
right way to do it or this is a better
way to do it I'll be like oh man like
thank you so much for showing me I'm not
gonna be like oh how dare you like the
worst thing about this software
engineering community this kind of
programming community a lot of the times
is that people just get very very like
superior and just refuse to listen to
everyone else and think everyone's
beneath them I'm definitely not one of
those people I hate those people to be
honest and I wish that they would be
better but the point is
this is like a safe space like I mean
I'm gonna learn a lot throughout this
series so you guys let's build this
thing together in a nice friendly
environment yeah okay so anyway that was
just kind of an example of what we can
kind of do so or like how pull requests
in general are done so anyway I'd see my
support of the project this one's huge I
don't know fault if I'll tend to this
one today because it's got 717
participants and I did I think I think I
did reply to this at some point
well even guest in his a administrator
or my discord replied to this and said
that I'm using premake instead of
seeming I mean it's kind of redundant
and there's a lot of other stuff here
but you can see this hasn't been closed
yet so there's stuff for me even four
days ago and you know he is pretty big
so yeah I'm not sure about this I might
I'll keep that open for now and it was
the very first issue as well which is a
very fast pull request which is
interesting so he able to go to that
okay add Linux support of the project
that's quite um ambitious I guess I'm
not sure how up-to-date this is um you
can see it's got conflicts which means
it's not up to date but so that is
support for Linux Primack file change
Beauvoir to fix the compiler error yeah
I mean like I'm obviously I'm happy for
like this to be I'm not sure why the
same because yeah so like sudden okay
sure
[Music]
can you please update this branch and
make sure it's ready to merge
and I'd be keen to merge this in and
I'll even add a smiley face
that's very either a slightly smiling
face yes I don't want to be like full
unhappy yet but I'll just yeah okay done
say you said like this is you know let's
do this okay I replace compiler flags
with pre make properties so I have two
pretty big file with properties the
runtime library yes so I think I've
already done that I believe so because I
think what the thing here was that yeah
back when we used MDD and all of that
stuff I believe that right now if we
look at the pre make file I believe
we're not doing that anymore right um
yes we're doing wrong time and we're not
doing like you know /m DD or about that
um the reason I had to check by the way
it's not because I'm that stupid that I
can't remember what we didn't want we
did and just sometimes like I mean I
have a hazel development branch this
access like accessible to patrons where
I do a lot of this kind of development
stuff and sometimes I don't remember
what I've done kind of for that
development branch all of the stuff that
I've actually done live in a video so
that's why sometimes I just need to
double check okay anyway um so this this
has been done recently not in there I'll
just say obsolete
thanks for the suggestion okay cool so
there we go
start project now I think this is
something that I want to do what was
that pretty big pile because we don't
have a start project I know that there's
a pre make flag for that it's called
stock project so that looks really good
at a star project let's thumbs that up
it's not a lot like Universal no really
I don't really find that I don't I don't
see the exactly this is good look at
this little discussion people are having
a nice discussion about maybe making
this one line of code better like that's
fantastic so really good obviously in
this case what I need to do that and we
can't even do that because yeah it's
pretty clear anyway to just mix them
boxes start a project I'm happy with
that I'm gonna measure sin right now so
the merge pull request oh yeah I don't
like the this is the title of the of the
merge isn't it I'm sure I like this that
much but yeah I guess github just likes
doing in that way so we'll just merge
that in okay that's now merged if you go
to the code in github you can see that
my latest commit was a merge pull
request
I'm 22 seconds ago if we look at the
commits here as well you can see that
there's that commit so now this person
is also contributed to hazel which is
really cool and also we get the you know
we get this code done so I can now kind
of pull that verified okay whatever I
don't know what that even means but
anyway I can now obviously pull the
changes into my local depository and I'm
happy that they're so I'm not even sure
you guys had to do that so um just in
case you're unaware so all I need to do
now is just pull I don't know if I've
got any kind of stuff I probably do have
on track stuff I don't know why I do
actually
ah this is just uh did I not commit this
maybe I didn't commit this no I must not
have committed this I asked fantastic
okay sometimes I forget to communicate
as well I really need to propose to
promote on my monitor so that I can
commit stuff but let's just commit that
stuff now
so what do we need that and that I think
that's it right what else is left don't
need that okay well I mean we might as
well commit this actually so what do we
do we added what was that in court of H
we had so if if debug is on and I might
actually the first thing on my right the
message is what we did regarding the
static library so we now link the
dynamic library instead of well I like
to get my community just pretty accurate
so you'll see this live and it's just
called the runtime libraries in it yeah
multi-threaded do DLL now linking
runtime library dynamically and define
that okay yeah git push well we also
need to pull I wish I pulled fast it
doesn't matter we've committed it it
should be a easy match
and then I can also push so just get
that done it's like cool you guys are
saving me do some stuff live here which
is pretty cool anyway now that's done
yeah if we refresh this repository we
should see this and it probably had to
merge yeah I did a little did a little
merge because I ended up committing
before I pulled the latest match that we
did so that was a little bit of fun
there but anyway that's done now cool
that's close obviously next one
dependencies in a solution folder I
grouped all the dependencies together in
a solution folder for Less cluttering
that's awesome I was
One Ring for a long time how to do that
I guess you just put it into a group
yeah I really like that I'll definitely
be using groups more often but in
general this is good so this is just um
adding a new line at the end of the file
that's fine yeah that that's pretty good
I like that so I'm going to merge that
[Music]
no I can't
okay cool I can't because I just updated
pretty much the primary file myself okay
fixed build fairly first time now first
check for digital very fault okay cool
actually if not exist yeah that's good
that's a good idea there was also
another one I think which was related
spam not sure which one's better there's
personal command for hazel project
modified this one show that X copy will
nor the document who is a folder on a
file so I'm not sure but this it was
referenced so I'm not sure why like why
was this ref like he referenced this
right so what does that mean exactly
oh that's a different one sorry that's
number nine this is 21
okay so there's been a few I mean this
what is this dude this this just splits
it up so this is instead of one argument
it's true but I'm not sure if that like
does that fix it okay let's let's
quickly report this so we have so the
idea is we can delete bin and then if we
try and build soundbox
it will fail the first time because the
folder doesn't doesn't exist yet so
let's see if we can actually fix this
right now because yeah that's really
annoying I agree okay so there it is
it's failed over here I hate all of this
all of these warnings we really need to
suppress them else online
because I think that things are that
fine I think that they just need to be
surprised but anyway okay so where's the
arrow there it is so command blah blah
failed so let's try let's try do this
instead so I'm just gonna copy this and
then go to the Premack file and there it
is paste this instead and then we need
to what do we need to do to go back here
when he still like bin we should
regenerate the projects I'm able to test
our partner for his scope should be one
space oh okay well maybe I shouldn't
have merged them project sandbox why was
that a failure
okay this brings me to another point
obviously ideally you should definitely
test the pull request before you
actually merge them in I have a feeling
that because this was automatically
merged it so it was done before hazel
start project sandbox that's interesting
I'm not sure maybe needs to be done
after but I'm not sure I mean obviously
like I imagined that this guy tested it
but we can let's just run that again
unable set start project and project
scope should be like okay so it's in a
project scope ask well because we've
included this stuff okay cool so this
needs to be done in the workspace start
so it maybe I'll do it up here so let's
try this again
okay there we go so we'll move it then
that makes sense because you immediately
see the start approaching the
architecture everything's fine okay cool
so now we've done that we'll make sure
that in case there's no bin folder let's
try and build sandbox and let's see if
it fails again I'm not sure if it will
no it didn't really built very quickly
there let's delete this and let's try
again I don't buy it
okay there we go that's exceeded okay
cool so splitting up the file was really
the solution the reason I like that
better
so okay that's brilliant so the reason I
like this a lot better than the other
one like cuz this this is more code
right so this has to do more it has is
doing if not exist blah blah but this is
like it's this is literally just like a
couple extra characters just splitting
up the path into the folder and the
actual like it into the directory and
the file which is really good is it
having like one big path so I'm really
happy with that I think that's a lot
better actually I don't even know it
like because that's the first argument
then we have the another path were
copying from I guess from and then we're
into semo's I don't know anyway well the
point is splitting it up into into two
arguments that seems to fix it I really
like this fix so I'm going to I'm going
to do my classic plays update this so I
can imagine because I could commit it
myself but I kind of want to give this
guy credit for doing it because yeah
this was an issue that's been bothering
me for ages so we'll give him a chance
to fix it we'll give him like a couple
days to update it and then also one
thing I want to do is this I will say
that sir
Oh blah blah okay cool so this is the
one that solution plan change provision
number nine how do I reference another
issue oh here we go
okay
I have that links properly it should I
don't know if it wants a space there but
whatever okay cool so close and comment
and then that's obviously I referenced
this and okay cool so there we go
that's everything done I'm really glad
we did that because we fixed up the
startup project we fixed that folder
thing copying and what else did we do
I think that was about it but anyway I
kind of took you guys through the whole
workflow so now that we have we promoted
or addressed everything there's kind of
an ongoing discussion but I think I'll
close eventually because see make I
don't think I'm still not sure if she
makes portrait ever be a thing and hazel
just because pre make assists and also
pre Mac I think can generate see make
files anyway so I know pretty much a
thousand times better than say making my
opinion anyway Linux support again I'd
be happy to kind of make sure that works
but I want to probably test that on a
Linux VM or something first
and then everything else we've addressed
so that's all the pull requests hope
that kind of makes sense as far as
opening pull requests really easy all
you have to do is kind of fork hazel
right so you can fork it into your own
kind of into your own account and then
once you've done that you can you can do
what you want in a branch or just in
your master in kind of your copy of the
repository and then once you once you
have done that you can just go to pull
request you pull request and then you
can merge you know your copy into my
copy right and that's it and this will
show you all the different as one might
say really smooth is the idea anyway
doesn't matter you guys won't get that
jerk but the point is you can kind of
create that merge that in and you can
say that's kind of how it works I will
once I do update that readme file I will
have more or less like a better kind of
like a format for like how you should
structure your messages and what
information you should provide here
because right now it's kind of just like
you know write whatever but I would like
that to be more structured in the future
but yeah that's about it hope that made
sense alright so that is pull requests
in github you can see how helpful that
is and how we could kind of just for now
it's really like small changes small
fixes because there isn't too much to
hazel to begin with but once we have you
know massive massive like amount of code
and our code base is just huge there'll
be so many things here and there that
people can improve and fix and implement
as well so pull requests obviously going
into the future if we can kind of start
ramping that up like as it is right now
that's perfect we can establish it we
can make sure that people are
comfortable with that because in the
future that's gonna be really important
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did even hit that like button you
can also help support the series by
going over to patreon icon for slash the
churner huge thank you as always to all
the patrons that make this series
possible do you guys support there
you'll get videos a week early as well
as access to that private hazel
development repository where you can see
like all the code that I've done which
is far more ahead of this kind of
repository so that's really cool and a
little kind of thank you for helping to
support this series um next time I think
we're gonna probably move on with actual
hazel development one thing that I
wanted to do for a while is like input
and key codes and stuff like that so we
can kind of do that yeah we'll probably
end up doing that I think so until next
time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]